yeah did you CU I feel like we all kind
of go through a certain point in time
where we grow up around certain people
or we're related to certain people and
you got to kind of you know not all
family is family and not all you know I
I I have homies of mine who like I just
outgrew him mentally
or yeah mine is not even that like these
fols are just TW weers outside now like
it's just it's not even that bad like I
wish it was like you got to grow up
cheat on your girl or not taking care of
your kid I wish I wish my homies were
just like you got to stop hitting your
girl bro like I'm going to beat your ass
again or something I wish so it was at
least like I know you're alive right I
only see my friends through arrest
reports bro and it makes me so [__]
sad wow my best homie Joe my best my
best [__] friend of all time first
time I talked to him 12 years I talked
to him last Christmas I saw him walking
this the streets I see him always always
but this time I'm like you look happy
and I talk to him and like first time I
talk to my best [__] friend I chill
with all day every day was going to move
in with right cuz he was just too much
he was taking like too many pills mixing
with this he was getting drunk I just
could not be around his ass no more he
just lives under the bridge with all
these old fools Jesus and like it just
made me [__] cry I couldn't I
couldn't believe it but I talked to him
recently and it like made my whole year
right he's doing better he looked like
he was doing better man he was drinking
a green juice oh okay he was just
walking down the
street and he didn't recognize me at
first he looked at me and then he like
we kind of like I could see in his face
that he was just like oh my god well
[__] I talked to his mom still his mom's
[__] amazing but she's like I can't
do anything for him anymore right
and I now he's back doing [__] up [__]
cuz I just saw cuz my homie is like yo
and send me the the link just so I can
check up on my homies like oh what's he
[__] how long is he going be oh [__]
okay then yesterday I got word that
before I was just talking about on the
podcast last week one of my old homies
I'm like I walked I drove into town in
my new car I'm like I'm going to take it
to town and I drove in and I just see
one of my old homies just twacked as
[__] riding a bike down the street just
twacked and then yesterday they told me
he [__] just died I didn't even know
he just de [__] so you just saw him and
I just saw him and talked about him on
the show the next week [__] dead what
the [__]
overdose they're they're still trying to
determine it but 100% how often do you
go back to Merced I used to go back a
lot but like four or five times a year
now maybe a little more for birthdays or
something right right right right all
your family's still there your mom's
still there everybody yeah yeah and my
fiance's family's from there too she's
from there okay cool right outside of
town but yeah Mercedes like like you
said earli it's kind of like it is a
gang town like there's dude this that
whole little pocket of Cali is active as
[__] yeah it's crazy like you wouldn't
even know it but it's easy to avoid stay
in your car go to [__] work don't
talk to [__] with gang tattoos
right don't go buy drugs go don't be
doing [__] that drug dealers do right
don't go to the nightclub maybe don't go
to the bars with fools with big
pants no for all this shit's real like
go to Applebee's and hang out yeah go to
go go seeing karaoke at Applebee's get
half price on your apps 100% half price
appetizers you can stay out of it you
can stay out of it fool say what are you
look at say sorry I was spacing out have
a good day yeah you don't have to check
everybody that tries to check like so
many people would be alive if they just
put their ego down slightly and go I'm
got kids to take care of and just kept
walking 100% you can stay out of you can
stay out of the [__] especially in a
small town small it's a small town like
we GB gb's homies are the homies I used
to avoid growing up you know I told him
I even told him cuz we just did a toy
drive in mer said at the gang Park but I
grew up right there cuz my grandma owns
an apartment building that touch is the
fence so that's the park I grew up in
and I remember like damn there's a lot
of gang banging ass fools out here like
I think I remember you as a kid 100 no
no no I I don't remember him but no I
mean like his friends maybe oh for sure
no a lot of his homies I remember yeah
um but like I just told a story recently
um you know like a the potato gun
shotguns you see those so some fool I
just told a story like some fool tried
to take my [__] head off when I was
like
I was getting food and full shot me in
the head with it like hoping to kill my
ass and just kept driving I just told
the story and I follow these fools to
12th Street where gb's Hall as [__]
homies from I was like hey man I just
told a story about your street isn't
that crazy and then two days later we do
a toy drive on 12 Street that I'm
talking about at this park it's all
renovated GB through this whole the
[__] Soccer United Soccer thing had a
booth felt like not a drug dealer for
sure anymore I felt so awesome and GB
just like he's making it happen out
there he's really making the town like
better and look better and all these
gang fools like yeah you could be a gang
banger there's people around
[__] be chill everybody be cool
pick up the trash like this is our
neighborhood I [__] love this fool
for that dude and
um yeah I just it's active if it's if
you're if you're trying to be active
right yeah I think so